C'est pas un putaclic,
C'est juste que, à un moment donné,
il vaut mieux que je le dise moi-même
avant que les gens ne s'en rendent compte.
Car oui, je vous le dit :
Je suis un mytho.
Et si vous êtes observateurs,
vous verrez que quelque chose à changé
euh... ici, là...
quelque part autour de moi...
Non, ce n'est pas mon nouveau
disque dur, ce sont mes lunettes !
Référen...
Ah, pu****, je ne vois plus rien !
[Rires]
Référence à la vidéo que vous verrez là,
ayé, j'ai enfin des lunettes et
oui, je peux vous le confirmer :
je suis aveugle !
Je suis aveugle mon gars !
Depuis que je suis petit,
je ne savais pas.
En fait c'est pour ça que
je suis dans mon monde :
Je ne voyais rien.
Et j'ai su ça une fois que
j'ai mis des lunettes.
J'ai fait : "Ah, pu**** !
C'est vachement bien fait la réalité !!
C'est fou quoi ! Tu vois ?
La définition et tout... c'est incroyable !
Et ce n'est pas grave,
je n'ai pas besoin de voir pour faire la vidéo.
Bon, alors : pourquoi je suis un mytho ?
Ben on va en parler de suite...
après le générique.
[Musique Générique]
Comme vous le savez, en ce moment
je suis en tournée de spectacle.
Ça veut dire que je pars de ville en ville
faire des spectacles
Et surtout, ce qui est intéressant,
c'est qu'on se voit après et qu'on discute.
Quelque chose m'est beaucoup revenu,
c'est aussi quelque chose que je lis
dans les commentaires
depuis janvier 2016 !
Et ouais, mon pote : ça date !
Et que je reçois par mail, par Facebook,
par Twitter, Instagram, Snapchat et Tinder.
L'une de ces informations est fausse.
Bon, cette fameuse question
que vous me posez souvent, c'est :
Comment fait-on pour devenir mentaliste ?
Est-ce qu'il faut acheter des livres
de mentalisme ou
faire des formations de mentalisme ?
Mais aujourd'hui j'avais envie
d'y répondre en prenant mon propre exemple.
Un mentaliste, mesdames et messieurs,
[Roulement de tambour]
est un mythomane !
Alors j'ai bien conscience qu'en
disant ça, ça veut dire
que je suis un mytho.
Et bé voilà, ayé :
c'était un prank.
Depuis le 1er janvier 2016,
tout ça n'existait pas.
Que des complices.
En fait c'était toujours le même
complice dans les vidéos
mais qui se maquille très très bien.
D'ailleurs vous avez eu l'impression
de voir Amixem ou Pierre Croce
par exemple :
ce n'était pas eux.
C'était toujours la même personne :
c'est ma soeur.
Ma soeur fait tous les complices.
#choquéetdéçu
Bon alors, pourquoi je dis que
je suis un mytho ?
Parce qu'il n'y a personne qui
va délivrer à quelqu'un en France
euh... ou en Europe
ou dans le monde,
le statut de Mentaliste Officiel !
Bpourrr, Bpourrrrr !!!
Ça n'existe pas.
Pour la simple et bonne raison
qu'il n'y a pas de définition
du mot : mentaliste.
Ça veut dire que tous les mentalistes
que vous verrez, que ce soit
sur Youtube, en spectacle,
à la télé, etc...
ce sont des gens qui,
comme moi,
moi le premier, hein ?
se sont levés un matin en disant :
Je m'auto-proclame Mentaliste.
C'est le mot que je vais utiliser
pour me définir.
Ce qui veut donc dire,
par extension,
que chaque mentaliste
a sa propre définition.
A plus ou moins de nuances,
ou parfois avec des grands fossés.
Ce qui explique aussi que,
parfois, je vous vois
vous prendre la tête
dans les commentaires.
Quand je lis parfois quelqu'un
qui dit :
"Oui, mais non ! Là,
il n'a pas lu dans ses pensées
donc il n'est pas mentaliste ! "
Et que l'autre lui dit :
"Non, mais si ! Il a déduit ça, ça, ça...
donc c'est ça du mentalisme ! "
Est-ce que c'est bien clair tout ça ?
Oui ?
Ma définition, je vous l'avais déjà
donnée une fois dans une vidéo
de l'année dernière, donc on
était bien moins nombreux qu'aujourd'hui.
Mais, pour vous la donner rapidement,
pour moi, le mentalisme,
Mon point de vue !
il n'est pas meilleur ou moins bon
que celui d'un autre mentaliste :
c'est un mélange de
techniques de déductions,
qu'elles soient psychologiques,
de lecture non-verbale,
tout ce genre de choses...
Qui vont nous permettre de déduire
une information qu'on cherche.
Toutes les techniques d'influence,
que ce soit du simple
forçage psychologique à
un encrage psychologique,
il y a peut-être de l'hypnose conversationnelle,
tout ce qui va me permettre,
en fait, d'influencer un choix...
Là-dessus, je saupoudre allègrement
de techniques de mémorisation
comme vous avez pu le voir sur la chaîne.
De toute manière, la chaîne
ressemble à ma définition.
Techniques de calcul rapide
ou, on va dire, d'une manière générale
d'une gestion plus optimum...
ou optimal..e
de son cerveau.
De techniques de prestidigitation
qui vont permettre, parfois,
d'essayer quelque chose
et si on se rate, on a quand même
une sortie de secours
qui sera plus faible et moins jolie
que ce qui était prévu au départ,
mais qui permet un minimum de
retomber sur ses pieds au niveau de...
de la dignité.
Et puis, là-dedans, il y a
le détournement d'attention aussi,
par exemple, qui est intéressant
quand il est psychologique.
Et enfin, d'une manière globale,
le fait d'essayer de comprendre
comment fonctionnent les choses,
d'une manière générale.
Donc une espèce de
curiosité exacerbée.
Donc ça c'était ma définition,
donc c'est comme ça que
je pratique mon mentalisme,
que ce soit dans les vidéos,
sur scène, euh...
au quotidien...
euh...
en allant chercher le pain.
Si demain je rencontrais quelqu'un
qui, juste en écoutant le bruit
que fait un moteur, est capable de dire
où se situe la panne dans la voiture,
et qui dit : "Ouais, je suis mentaliste...
je suis mentaliste carrossier ! "
Et bien il aurait tout à fait le droit.
Ce qui me permet de vous emmener
maintenant à l'objet ultime de cette vidéo :
c'est que je vous déconseille d'acheter
d'une manière générale,
des livres :
"Devenez mentaliste en deux jours"
"En deux heures"
"10 minutes ?"
ou des formations pour devenir mentaliste.
Là aussi, encore une fois, attention :
[Effet d'annonce dans la voix]
DISCLAIMER !!!
Je ne dis pas que ces livres là
sont biens ou pas biens,
je ne les ai pas forcément lu
de toute manière.
Je ne dis pas qu'ils n'ont pas
un bon contenu.
Je n'en sais strictement rien.
Votre définition et vos attentes
ne seront peut-être pas
du tout celles qu'il y a dans le livre.
Exemple très concret :
Un jour en achetant un livre
de mentalisme,
qui était fort intéressant,
au demeurant,
j'y ai trouvé un livre quasiment
consacré au palm reading,
à la lecture des lignes de la main.
Alors c'était passionnant
parce que je ne connaissais pas ça
et, euh..., ça me plaît toujours, en fait,
dans savoir plus dans ce domaine là.
Qu'on y croit ou pas, en fait,
ce n'est pas le problème.
Le problème c'est toujours :
Est-ce que je peux découvrir autre chose
et essayer de comprendre
pourquoi ça fonctionne,
pourquoi les gens y croient.
Mais, tu vois, entre ma notion
du mentalisme et
les lignes de la main,
il y avait quand même un fossé, quoi...
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire...
Définissez vous-même
qu'est-ce que le mentalisme pour vous ;
et dans cette définition vous allez
dégager des grands thèmes
comme moi je l'ai fait tout à l'heure,
et sur ces grands thèmes,
vous allez pouvoir
aller plus vers, euh...
la lecture des micro-expressions,
par exemple
ou sur des livres de référence
sur la mémoire...
comme les livres de Tony Buzan
dont je vous ai souvent mis
les liens dans la description
par rapport aux vidéos de mémoire
Vous allez pouvoir composer vous même
en fait, votre propre chemin,
votre propre formation.
Voilà !
Écoutez, je vous fais, de toute manière
une petite ordonnance,
vous, euh... vous faites un like de vidéo
avec, peut-être, un petit commentaire
qui fera plaisir.
Vous me faites ça
une fois par vidéo pendant 1 mois
et ça se passera bien.
Vous pouvez vous abonner
comme d'habitude
et rendez-vous très bientôt !
Extrêmement bientôt !
Peut-être même demainnnnn....
ou après-demain.
En fait, j'ai un gros montage à finir,
là, pour vous.
Je voulais le sortir aujourd'hui.
Mais, han !
C'est pas du tout bon aujourd'hui...
Donc demain ou après-demain.
Ciao !
[Musique générique de fin]